da finde ich wirklich den wahnsinn
gerade haben wir noch vom kampf der
quantencomputer berichtet und schon
kündigt ibm den kommerziellen betrieb
des ersten universell einsetzbaren
quantencomputer kann allerdings kaufen
kann man ihn nicht aber wie kommt man an
den rand hier erklärt jetzt auf jeden
fall das zeitalter der quantencomputer
hat tom herzlich willkommen bei klick
zum kleinsten on tour
wirklich bahnbrechend wird die welt
revolutionieren ibm bereitet dem betrieb
des ersten universellen quantencomputer
vor jetzt im ersten halbjahr 2017 werden
bereits programmierschnittstellen
vorbereitet die die verbindung zu den
herkömmlichen computern auf der einen
seite und dem ibm quantensystem
herstellen jeder kunde soll dann über
die ibm klausel aufzuweiten können
die fanden technologie arbeitet dabei im
hintergrund wer mit einem
quantencomputer arbeiten will muss
lediglich mit den apps also den
application programming interfaces den
programmierschnittstellen die von ibm
bereitgestellt werden programmieren von
computern muss man nicht verstehen es
ist der erste supercomputer einer neuen
generation durch die quantentechnologie
können aufgaben viel schneller berechnet
werden und der datenverkehr funktioniert
über verschenkte teilchen es ist
wirklich bemerkenswert für moderne
computer eine ewigkeit brauchen können
franken computer viel viel viel
schneller rechnungen aber auch ungenau
das hat mir ja in unserem video über den
kampf der quantencomputer eine
revolution ibm rechnet mit fortschritten
maschinen komplexen problemen
medikamentenforschung berechnungen in
der logistik finanzwirtschaft 50
intelligenz datensicherheit zitat
heutige computer systeme sind
außergewöhnlich leistungsfähig und
werden auch weiterhin eine zentrale
rolle in wirtschaft und gesellschaft
spielen es gibt aber eine reihe von
herausforderungen die mit diesem
computer nicht zu bewältigen sind dafür
brauchen wir quantencomputer so familia
senior vice president ibm systems
bisschen wirklich vor einem neuen
zeitalter der informationstechnologie
und wahrscheinlich schon bald werden wir
in ziemlich ausgefuchsten app auch
wandten computer zugreifen können wenn
ihr mehr über kranken computer und
datenübertragungen mit
quantentechnologie erfahren wollt dann
klickt auf diese playlist mit unserem
bisherigen videos zum thema und hier
könnt ihr mir ein abo aufsaugen vergesst
nicht mehr einen auf die glocke zu geben
damit er wirklich nicht erfasst und
ansonsten bleibt dran